ils étaient une vingtaine ce matin à
assister à la rencontre proposée aux
pavés du canal dans le cadre de la
quinzaine de la librairie ses élèves de
première l au lycée breteuil de montigny
le bretonneux ont pu découvrir deux
métiers de la chaîne du livre celui
d'auteur avec joy sorman venu parler de
son ouvrage sciences de la vie la
profession également deux libraires
souvent mal connue par les jeunes c'est
important de d'ouvrir la librairie aux
lycéens de leur montrer que c'est un
lieu voilà qui est facile d'accès qui
est ouvert que c'est pas un lieu un peu
sanctuariser que c'est c'est quelque
chose qui est accessible et ouvert aux
étudiants aussi une action de la région
ile de france pour sensibiliser à
l'univers du livre et de la lecture
chaque jeune reçoit la fin de la
rencontre un chèque de 18 euros à
dépenser dans une librairie
le rendez vous au palais du canal a été
apprécié les lycéens ont pu échanger
directement avec le libraire est
l'auteur du jour c'est toujours un
plaisir de parler avec des artistes en
fête
surtout quand moi je devenir chanteur
donc même si c'est une écrivain c'est
c'est ça reste une artiste on a pu
justement donner notre avis sur ce qu'on
pense de littérature aujourd'hui et
plein d'autres choses c'était très
intéressant
il ya des vraies révélations il ya
quelque chose qui se passe l'écriture un
livre c'est profond et donc ça vient
remuer des questions vraiment intime
parfois et ça ça vient souvent là et ce
moment la quinzaine de la librairie se
déroule jusqu'au 25 mai près d'une
cinquantaine de rencontres va se tenir
dans toute l'île de france